hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to blameless a free [ __ ]
game available on Steam that supposedly
is very good but I say that for a lot of
freelance so I take job offers as they
arise so when this guy called me I was
relieved I could finally get a paying
job he said he needed help with interior
design for his house that he was
building I always respected people who
can do construction so I naturally
agreed to come and take a look I already
had a couple of ideas it was already
quite late but he insisted on me coming
over the same day and I tried to comply
because I didn't want to lose this offer
drove there with my car his house was
all the way over in the suburban area
quite remote but with other houses
nearby quiet place the man met me at the
front gate
it was a temporary fence and the gate
was made of rotting wooden planks he
started showing me around the yard it
seemed weird that there was a large
garbage container blocking the way so we
had to go through the garage to get
inside the house he took me through the
rooms so I started looking around at one
point I saw stain and at first glance it
seems like brick dust but then I
realized - his blood spilled on the
floor
thought maybe there was another worker
who got injured so I turned to tell the
man that's when I saw his hand raised to
hit me he was holding a metal rod Oh
before I could defend myself he hit me
in the head
Oh juice to passed out I don't know how
long I was out when I woke up
perhaps there's going to be some
interesting twist to this cuz I imagine
I don't know I first I thought this is
gonna be a fixer-upper house yeah that
hurt maybe you should be a little more
concerned to the fact that someone tried
to murder you or maybe it was your own
blood and you're just seeing it in the
future oh this looks lovely
oh this Dyke amber my mouth anymore
oh there we go okay well we just had a
little hiccup but apparently sua seems
to be going this blood stain does not
look like it's a result of a banal
injury are you talking about a banal
injury all right so why oh hello
I might be able to get further through
the Attic why would you be able to do
that just bash your way out of the
windows Gangnam style I mean they don't
seem too sturdy I mean everything does
seem to be falling apart also I don't
know why you came all the way out here
just to be murdered oh I've got a weapon
now habu ski
I can't whack no [ __ ] give me that I
probably need this for some reason or
another okay I don't know why I'm doing
this but I need to do it again drink
okay I should bend the rod but it's too
tough to do my am oh you mean you're a
little baby wimpy baby can't bend it
with your own muscles come on man
I so I gotta find spell oh hello 9 Wynn
wound Oh
I don't look too good the phone is
smashed no way it's gonna work anytime
soon
well then why do I have it I mean it's a
Nokia it should last forever okay so I
got an inventory here ooh a lot of dust
flowing from the ceilings which isn't a
good sign
oh so this game is like can I use this
pipe to bend the rod I don't know how
I'd be able to do that but I'm gonna try
hello Kurt uncles oh that works weirdly
well that was ingenuitive miss okay so
now it's got I can take it well now I've
got a bent rod I sure can't beat the
[ __ ] out of anybody that wants to hit me
with a metal rod pull this open hell
yeah
well that sounded really scary so what's
up here hello oh I hate poking my head
in an attic I can't see what's behind me
so might as well get up huh it's dark
yeah no joke is dark suck it up and move
along I don't seem good okay I hope that
I hope it was thunder I was just about
to say there we go
yeah there we go what do we go what are
you talking about where are we going I
don't know where we're going what are
you doing alright nothing else up here
oh okay what do you - my wallet comes up
mine
you see a library card belonging the
Helen Woodward get here I don't like
that I do anything else about that or
was that the literally I picked the
right card to pick up because apparently
there's nothing else here because
nothing else would have a name on it
okay someone's being murdered in this
place that's no bueno
that's no bueno okay so am I gonna be
murdered next it seems bad this it's
long pliers oh so I need a wire cutter
and then I need a wood cutter or maybe I
just need to sack up and shoulder that
door open so there's gotta be something
oh hello hi crowbar I'll be with you in
just a second
Oh a bolt good can I take another do I
only need one it's stuck underneath the
beam what can't be that stuck it's a
crowbar use it to leverage the beam up
hold the whole building open okay your
tongue goes oh oh uh uh I don't know
what benefit that did but it didn't do a
whole lot I'll take this instead and I'm
gonna I'm gonna break all the wires open
no one's gonna stop me it's it's over
this way
Herbert jerk cutters are broken what
things on that handle should attach
that's missing okay so I gotta go back I
gotta put it on the bench I gotta put a
nut in the bowl
I get it I see this I see this okay so I
need first things first I need ooh maybe
I can like yeah I can place this yeah
just like that okay and then I could
chuckles this up oh so I am gonna lift
the house
hooray and then I can open the door her
boggy bit oh I thought I had that come
on tell me I'm smart maybe I can grip
uncle's these off huh okay let's go to
her yeah
oh well then what were the wires doing
with the wires doing anything oh it's
outside how about I just hop the fence
and get the fudge out here did I see
something over there hang on I my brain
was like analyzing oh hey [ __ ] okay
sorry that was a bit of an overreaction
for that situation
I apologize I'll try to contain my [ __ ]
next time and heed my own advice and
sack the [ __ ] up
[Music]
anybody here hi hello how are you doing
I'm fine thank you for welcoming to your
home me by the way not welcoming anybody
okay hello Kurt uncle's so that doesn't
work and I abandoned some wire cutters
for some reason don't know why and I
didn't need it
gee hello okay
hellooo I don't like the look of that
dark corridor me neither
see if the light switch is working now
let's sprint down it okay everything is
as it should be
I can't see a goddamn thing why am I in
here
I open the windows no I cannot I
shouldn't be here
I should be running away hey this
doesn't work that's good to know
oh this one doesn't have a light switch
why is any part of this house finished
where did they get this murder home
murder apocalypse so there's nothing
here there was no point to this oh this
one oh yeah I could have done that at
any time at any moment I could have done
that not dead I did it the stupid way
and I vastly apologize okay what is that
there's nothing what is this also
nothing what is this ooh ah oh yes no
did it why is it pointed up why is it
pointed directly up you see it seems to
be working but okay but anyway I got it
I suppose it's working enough maybe
pointing up so I get ambience lighting
and not so directional maybe oh well
that was a cheerful cheerful change okay
anyway so we got the flashlight oh hello
ah I couldn't have opened that any
creepier Oh finally yeah the house yeah
am I free can I go now can I go now
why do I need to run I hate it when you
tell me why I need to run when you tell
me I need her odd is usually a bad thing
locked
locked ones a locked why would it be
locked where's n-bit oh I'm bashing the
flashlight into my chin okay
you do need this year Lou
is anybody home also how the hell do I
get out of here it's at the dead body no
that's just plants can I go up here no
gonna go here no how about it through
these doors no this one
no how about through here yes anybody
hello or dark rooms hell yeah I love
dark rooms dark rooms are the best is
when I walk into dark rooms I get to
punch people in the face Oh is
everything always along because it's a
murder house you idiot me idiot you me
everybody he she we idiot why is
everything always along okay so this is
locked I gotta find something for that
or go back and get the crowbar but
that'd be just god damn dick ulis Oh
key I go in here hello hi oh let me let
me move these let me move these cuz I'm
a smart I'm one of the smarts okay boink
hello hi should I lock myself in here I
can't okay nevermind then what's that
hello hello is that banana broken okay
let's see
dear mr. Hopkins this is informing that
according to our records as of July 12th
2001 we still haven't received back the
scaffolding or the three sir pension
ladders he borrowed from the dared root
constructions please a turn
they'll be solely your responsibility
and a cat will 13 July 2000 I just read
that I get it I get it I get it but
there's something buying me okay so is
there something else important okay so I
know what I need to do I need to find
according to that letter there's three
total there's one already on that
scaffolding there's one broken in the
office and then I just need to find
another one somewhere around here before
I get horribly stabbed in the butt I
mean I don't think there's a good way to
get stabbed in the butt every as far as
I know but you know probably not not too
many good ways oh I bet it was back if I
go back uh
I bet it was somewhere back I could
probably take it because I remember
using a ladder somewhere or did I use
them no that was in the elevator or the
Attic the elevator yeah oh whoa hey whoa
whoa hey hey that's good how's it going
there you just taking a nap please she's
she's dead yeah oh hey I should turn the
lights on in here I didn't see anything
it's dust it's dust I want to look at
her face why not huh okay she have keys
yeah she has keys Dungey oh my dress of
this house she invited here too yeah to
work on the light and the water
very good job okay so I got two keys
that's Andy okay good bye now
Oh No why didn't I check this place more
thoroughly I was stumbling around in the
dark I probably stepped on her okay well
she's dead and then they're gonna kill
me oh my god okay so I need to get the
key out of here one of these for this
huh boink okay good going in I'm gonna
assume that was ghosts running away
screaming from me cuz I'm so scary
oh this sounds like death this is the
way out
is it is it now is this the way out oh
you you think you think this is the way
out okay I'll go to hacksaw or a table
saw to chop
[Music]
oh nice barrels can I jump up you whoop
his ass punching loader I can't jump up
you but I bet I can get up there with
the some bum bun joder
okay I've got a sambaramba mo burr I'll
just put the some blammo Kadota on here
huh fumbles I did it but first I'm gonna
go see if this key works on the back
lock and I don't know why it would be
locked back there why she would have the
key in her hands oh no way it's all gone
okay so oops what did I do okay oops
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna take this nut
for safety then go up this ladder I
don't have any more keys okay Scootaloo
little loop me little loop I'm up
ah what why why why why am i free my
free plug is like I can take a [ __ ] am i
dying get away from me get away you
don't get away get away
but it dumps I want that back happen let
them look
stay where you are i endu [ __ ]
you're under a rush I'm not I'm going I
was late but I didn't do anything
get on your knees now
[Music]
under arrest Oh am i you didn't read me
my Miranda rights well what the hell
this is what happened he was chasing me
with a rod in his hand he must have
hidden when he saw the police cars
pulling up to the gate uh-huh mr.
Malcolm we searched the yard thoroughly
and didn't find any evidence suggesting
there was another man no no he was there
he was the owner who called me the
former owners sold the house due to
personal financial problems two weeks
ago they moved to a different town on
the other side of the country the
private company Owens had now proved all
their employees were off-site having a
team-building activity that night how
could you not find evidence of him I'm
telling you he was there I heard you our
officers got a phone call from one of
the neighbors reporting lights coming on
in the house and suspicious person
moving on site they gave us your
description they never saw another man
how could that be this doesn't make any
sense it's like the crap does make
pretty clear sense to me I have to say
that I honestly don't believe any part
of your [ __ ] story that you're
giving me here everything suggests that
you murdered that woman oh I found the
victim's blood on your clothes in your
hands you had the victim's wallet in
your pocket and the officers caught you
fleeing the crime scene you no one else
guess whose fingerprints match the ones
we
the victim's body huh I don't know why
you murdered that woman but I'll
guarantee you're never getting out
you're going down mr. blameless ha oh I
get it okay I see now well hey this
occur none dirham how do we know we
can't trust this guy or maybe there was
another way to play where you could like
peace more things together we're there
more than one ending to that because I I
didn't have to pick up the wallet that
was something that I picked up so maybe
maybe there's like another ending oh I
love that the smooth jazz eNOS of this
outro here really counteracts all that
fun times we're having in the site there
yeah this is how I dance was a club
cranking it up that's how it all began
for me and it was far from over
well where's a mean will you mean by
that what do you mean okay
and I got see something about this
because I am confuzzled
so I just found out there was like a
completely different way to play that I
I want to go back in because I'm very
very curious where's it gonna leave off
if I continue Oh Isis
oh why did you do that to me there's
choices in this to make things work in
different ways and I'm wondering if
there's a different ending to be got
because I'm going to show you right now
that you can like right away do
different things and and like that's why
I was so confused because you had the
copper pipe that you could bend it with
but also if you look right in here oh
never mind it's doing some here there is
a hammer I didn't know that there was a
hammer in that one I thought saw
something else in the walkthrough
okay well never mind is oh there's
something else in there there are like
what do you do with this what do you do
with a hammer what do you do theater
okay so like I don't have to pick up
that wallet I really don't I don't have
to pick up the flashlight it's not
needed it's not even beneficial but what
I can do is I can go over here pick up
this pick up the pliers and maybe I'll
be just a little bit quieter about that
but and then you can move this and then
take this and put it in there there your
hoops and then you've got whoa I have
[ __ ] that up haven't I
well I do they work hey they work and
then you just break it without causing
any noise and then hopefully you can get
out of here all stealth like Johnny grab
the wallet
I didn't grab none of that I know right
super scary everything always long well
why don't you just stop bitching and
because I got a solution we're dark
anything useful here I don't know this I
don't know ah I believe this thing can
open fuse boxes okay how about oh the
bow the box okay anything else in there
not that I can tell hey hey oh hello our
CD 240 test monthly this switch looks
important okay RC these these are
already on these are all these are
already these are all these are these
are these are these are holy on honey if
the circuit trips again first turn the
RCD switch the smallest one then the
rest of on the orange one last make sure
the first here you first here click
after you turn the RCD it may take a
couple of seconds otherwise it'll trip
again I need to take a look at this
before we hand the keys to the new owner
okay so first the RCD hear a click may
take a couple seconds okay so our CD too
far CD 240 test monthly this switch
looks important okay so do something
about it there's gotta be a way that I
can like that I can uh oh but I can't
open this anymore
locked well then what the hell what was
the point of all that why did I need to
do that what's gonna trip nothing's
gonna trip there was nothing to trip oh
man it was worth a shot I think I'm
stuck I I might not have gotten
something that I needed from before but
I can't open the garage door now and I
can't open the garage I feel like it's
connected there somewhere but I just
don't know the answer dude so I'm gonna
leave this here so thank you everybody
so much for watching if you want to try
and find an answer to this you can play
the game for yourself it's totally free
so I'll put a link down in the
description below so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]